this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life
and your money i'm john dolone joined
here by best selling author
ramsey personality and all around good
human being rachel cruz how are you
doing great john yeah family's good yeah
we're good
just surviving you know for real sort of
thriving too it's sort of thrice yeah
it's almost a week can you sort of
thrive it's almost the weekend
thrive sounds like uh yeah i don't know
if you can sort of drive thrive it is
what it is we're there
we're there very cool well we are taking
your calls on life and
money and relationships and all the
things
that we can help you with rachel's
really smart and i will help drive today
so give us a shout at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to carlos in
tampa florida carlos what's going on
hey how are you guys doing thank you for
taking my call you bet man thanks for
calling what's up
so um i came from south america i
married my wife here in the united
states
uh we have a baby five months old now
and now we're trying to figure out what
to do next uh
what my plan was to get into a mortgage
and get a house
um i came with now that
but my wife has an 80 000 student loans
and right now we have
enough to pay it off i mean i'm talking
about like 95
000 and the student loans is 80 000.
um but i'm trying to figure out what if
we should prioritize that
instead of thinking about getting into a
mortgage and i'm just getting trying to
get that advice from you guys
carlos you're a stud man how did you
guys accumulate 95 000 dollars
uh cyber security man i.t that made it
my wife worked hard
cyber security bro we got it that's
awesome man
hey those tech jobs they are they're
paying she's an elementary school
teacher as well so
so that also helps that's awesome that's
fantastic so great well carlos number
one congrats on the baby
i know your life has just been turned
upside down in all the most wonderful
ways so congrats
so our rule of thumb here when we talk
about buying a home
is that we say we want you completely
out of debt
and a three to six months worth of an
emergency funds
so your expenses that total three to six
months have that saved in the bank
and then save up for a down payment from
10 to 10 to 20 for that down payment so
those are that's the tactical the the
what now the why behind all of that
is that you'll realize soon after you
are
in a home and own a home that a home
home ownership is extremely expensive
things happen i mean just the other day
our gutters
screwed up we had an ice storm in
nashville and all of our gutters filled
with eyes half of them fell off the
house i mean it's just
i had to get a new roof out of we got it
inspected high fived
and then two months later we gotta get
it we went crawl space last weekend
before a date and uh an inch of water in
the car like i mean it's just
stuff just happens when you own a home
and it's expensive
and so what ends up happening is a lot
of people rush into home ownership
because it's kind of the dream right
like you own a home and it's exciting
and it's fun
but you have no money you have debt and
you have no money and people go in
and end up that this house becomes a
burden
and a curse rather than the blessing
that it should be so
carlos if i woke up in your shoes
tomorrow i'd write a check for the
student loans
i get it i get it it's gonna hurt carlos
it's not fun but listen
but it is fun because at the other end
of it though you have no payments you
have
nothing and then if you want to bump the
rest of that 15 grand up depending on
your expenses
save that and then save a little bit on
the side you guys are killing it for a
down payment
then i would buy a home because i
promise if you go this route even though
it sounds just like this simple formula
you will move into that home and when
something comes up it's more like an
inconvenience than a complete crisis
right so one question i had out yeah
one question i had on that is should we
be waiting or trying to wait for
a loan forgiveness now that they're
giving away some kind of forgiveness for
teachers
is that something i should be looking
forward to
well there's talk of student loan
forgiveness from dc
but pieces of it or yes but honestly
here's the thing about the legislation
all of that like it's not like the
president of the united states
can just wave a wand and it happens like
there's a due process
it has to go through to actually let
that happen
and we don't know if it will when it
will so in my mind carlos
i don't want to i don't want to depend
on washington d.c
to change my life or waiting on them to
do things
i i'm going to control what i can
control and right now you can control a
lot like
you yourself without dc can do a lot for
your family and
not to get too political but they
promise stuff i mean if you remember
10 12 years ago they said if you went to
school and took out loans they would
forgive those loans if you worked in a
certain sector now
so it's not happening carlos i had a
ringside seat watching
some of the most brilliant minds
combined with some of the most
extraordinary
young men and women who went to law
school and i was an administrator to law
school
and many of them chose to go into the
public sector
to help the least of these in our
communities because of
the public forgiveness program and then
it was
year six year seven after practicing
when suddenly they would apply to have
these loans forgiven
and they were either it just completely
ignored or rejected
right right and here's the other part
carlos and this is just me i'm a guy who
signed up for a bunch of loans
i got a i got we got too many degrees in
our house between me and my wife
we signed up for a bunch of loans we
didn't know what we were doing but we
we did we saw the numbers they just
weren't real and we saw them like oh
that's a
problem for future don to handle i have
a integrity i've got an ethical issue in
my soul
i told somebody i'm gonna pay you back
if you help me get through school
you guys carlos y'all are of means you
all figured it out y'all have worked
really hard and you've got this money
here
for me it's a matter of you know we can
we don't need to wait on the government
we're not gonna wait on the government
they may or may not who knows and it's
gonna come with strings you gotta have
um you know public service all this
other stuff you guys have
worked hard you told somebody hey if you
give us this money we're gonna pay you
back
pay him back pay him back and then be
done with it wipe your hands of it
you'll have in a few months you'll save
up that emergency fund
and then it's off to the races i think
that's a great point too and
i mean just to applaud you carlos i mean
you guys are killed i mean he's from
what do you say costa rica from yes uh
south america
or south america yeah i mean came in
killed it
i mean you're i mean you're doing
amazing carlos and you guys can do this
you can do it the numbers are here and
you're only going to go up from here
that's the exciting part is
um like you said you have me like it's
there because because you did
what was right you know what's right
like yeah so i hope that helps carlos
and um probably more important than that
calls this
um you mentioned in that last call
right before a date y'all were hanging
out in the crawl space i have to i have
to explore this with you
we can go here it's not that interesting
no winston
my dates are different me and sheila's
dates are different we don't start in
the attic winston
has a crawl space that's like his man
room like down under the house like
where his tool bench is
like the the shock in the crawl space
well like say crawl sites you can stand
up in it
so i guess it's taking space for the
stance space
there's no it's not a basement because
it doesn't have heating and air and all
that like it's
anyways it's not that interesting it was
he went down to check on a mousetrap if
you really want to know
because there were mice down there and
he was going to get seattle's mouse
dropping
inch of water inch of water so we got to
go again i love
our reservations are in 30 minutes he's
like i gotta go get a pump and i was
like
sounds like the beginning of a classic
rom-com to me this is a classic
rom-com hey we got a date hey everybody
let's head down to the crawl space
it's called i i don't know
money and relationships 825 5225
give us a shout and we will walk along
with you glad you're with us this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm john deloni
joined here by best-selling author and
good friend rachel cruz and we are
taking your calls on life
and money triple eight eight two five
five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five the board's lit up and kelly's
waiting for your call
let's go to adam in syracuse new york
adam what's going on
oh no how much dr d just come back from
work
um calm because i was wondering how to
get my wife on board with everything
that dave says
you know i've been doing the program
since
late january and i got about
40 000 in debt
not including her vehicle with her
vehicle it'd be about 55
and i just want to change my family tree
and be able to purchase our first home
by next year
oh man well i appreciate your heart dude
and congratulations on turning this
first corner here
rachel you've you've heard this question
for years and years talking with couples
yeah so adam what's her biggest
hesitation what what causes her not
to want to get on board um
well she's she works full time as a
nurse at the va
and she's also going to school
for her rn and i think she's really
focused on that
which i'm super proud of her for but i i
really don't know her hesitation she
when i first mentioned dave to her she
got out online and
read some negative reviews those are out
there
for all of us i'm like believe what you
want to believe i go this guy is making
absolute sense to me
and i'm with it it's just hard to do it
by yourself yeah
you're right it's almost impossible to
do it by yourself if two of you are not
on the same page okay so what i so it
doesn't sound like
she is because i talked to some people
in the spouse is like oh i don't want to
budget i just want to have fun and not
be accountable
or some people say i just want to
continue to do what i do because
i i deserve it you know i mean like
there's kind of some entitlement
issues that i hear a lot but i don't
hear that from her i just hear that
she's skeptical
of the process so
i mean she she's the saver and i'm the
spender and
yeah um i'm i limit myself on everything
oh so
well i was gonna ask i mean i just so i
wonder if it just sounds like a really
big thing to
to to bite off for her because she has
all these other things she's doing and
she's thinking oh this thing is going to
take over but what you both have to
understand is that yes when we say work
as a married couple you definitely work
together
but one of you naturally is probably
going to do more and be more excited
than the other like winston
he's the nerd in our relationship like
he's the one that honestly does the
excel
he we do every dollar for a monthly but
he has an excel thing to map out
the future he always wants to talk he
you know he'll want to talk about it i'm
the one that's like uh
i kind of want to watch the bachelor
like i don't like you know that doesn't
mean i'm not on board but i'm not as
excited as he is or he's the one that
pays all of our bills he
he does it all even though i know what's
being paid and we're on the same page so
so for her she just you just need her to
you guys come together and agree hey we
want to start this process but the heavy
lifting of the tactical day-to-day
can honestly come from you adam and that
that's okay from from our perspective
adam how did you bring it up to her um
you know we were laying in bed one night
talking yeah that's your problem
stop are you serious awesome okay so
it's great
you're laying in bed you roll over and
you flutter your eyelashes at her and
she flutters alice's back at you and you
say baby
have i got a deal for you is that how
that went
yeah kind of come on man you gotta be
more smooth than that how long have you
been married
eleven eleven years been together yeah
eleven years
oh adam man okay so a couple things that
you said that i want to make sure
are you a schemer have you always had
some things
do you always are you the guy who brings
good ideas she's a saver she's a nurse
she's
working in hospital like she's she's
predictable yeah are you the guy was
like hey
listen yeah
yeah i think i am so you
when you first called you talked about
her car payment
your debt and so what i would tell you
is you guys have a pronoun problem
and what i mean is if you have a you and
a her in a marriage
and then the u is coming to the uh oh
i'm sorry you're not
you're all just together okay you all
been together for 11 years
yeah we have two children together and
i've been together for 11 years
uh okay so if you
haven't committed right if you all are
just riding this out together as
a in a committed relationship why aren't
y'all married can i ask yeah you can ask
um i i think she's afraid of commitment
is she afraid she's with you for a
decade sounds like she's afraid of you
that could be they very well could be
adam you know the truth is is that is
that real is that real
uh honestly i don't know
but you're probably right on the money
so here's what i would suggest brother
i would suggest sitting down with her
and talking about what's the future
going to look like
when you have two kids when you're not
married when you've been together for a
decade
suddenly the days turn into weeks and
the weeks turn into months and suddenly
you've been together three years and
five years and we'll think about this
later and suddenly the future starts to
happen in front of you
and that's when one of you peels off to
go back to school to start trying to
create their own future because we're
clearly not on the same page i've got
mine you've got yours
i'm gonna go make some more money for me
so i get a different car for me and
suddenly
you're gonna wake up and you're both
gonna be sitting on a couch
and you're gonna be two inches apart
from each other you can be two thousand
miles away from one another
and coming in with something like this
program which is we've gotta work
super close together not close together
we have to be one on this deal
because it's hard and it is back and
forth and
months on top of months and suddenly you
wake up and you're a united couple and
you're two or three years down the road
and you have this entire new trajectory
so when you talk about want to change
your family tree
right now you got two plants in the same
house so at first you got to do is you
got to
decide we're going to have one tree
we're going to do this one thing
together
and we're going to raise these kids in a
certain way we're going to build a
future together and a part of building
the future together rachel is
we're going to do money together right
so your heart is right adam
your spirit is right your ideas are
right but they're just out of order
right now
and the first thing you got to do is to
circle back to this extraordinary woman
you've
you've you've created a life with the
last decade plus
and say hey let's make this a unified
thing moving forward right for sure and
the richness that comes from that so not
just
the commitment to say we're gonna get
married not just the commitment that
we're gonna work together money not just
the commitment that we're gonna do
parenting together well
like that whole life that you're
bringing together it's almost like all
these separate puzzle pieces and you
start to bring it together and it is a
beautiful thing
while i feel like people stop marriage
it's stable
right yes there's something about it
that the richness of your life
it increases because there's a level of
vulnerability
and unity that you've never experienced
before
to say hey we're going to be in this
together and it's
it's something that i feel like is it
it enhances your life and it's something
about there's something about being
tethered in being anchored in not even
knowing that
yeah and i'm going to fall off this
mountain sometimes but i'm not going to
die
right i may bang up the side of it but
i'm anchored into something
yeah and somebody may shove me off she
may shove me off
but we are anchored in here right and
yeah it's circling back to we got to be
on the same page
working to gather
how hard is it so you guys how long have
y'all been married 11. 11 years okay
there's a myth that all of a sudden you
wake up one day and you figured it out
and there's no more discussions no more
eye rolls no more whatever when it comes
to budgets
right that's not true right no
no i mean i think the logistical side of
the budget goes pretty quick
like the budget meeting quote-unquote
like we'll talk when we do it and it
sounds like oh of course she does but we
really really do
yeah before the month begins we sit down
we're like hey let's look at march okay
well we're going
to the beach this week on spring break
we're gonna do this and this and you
start kind of mapping out
and we and so all of that takes eight to
ten minutes like we do that fast
but it's the other parts of knowing
being known by each other
in a deep way because money is it's it
reveals a lot of
who you are and so working that closely
with your spouse
yeah i can create some moments where
you're like oh i mean i'll be honest
like i
love amazon right now i know people hate
amazon but i'm like i can't stop
and and like and it's under his like he
created the account years ago whenever
we got prime and so we obviously just
share the account but i know every time
i buy something
it's he gets a notification i'm always
like even though it's in the budget and
i know it
i'm the spender and he's the saver so
even those things and i'm like hey just
heads up
i'm getting um a new pan because our
non-stick
you know we really needed the house and
we needed it
but it creates it just creates the
conversation that's right that's just
what i love
so and so for those of you out there who
are three years in five years in
it does get easier it gets more routine
but it always brings you back to a
conversation that's right
right that's right we had one at tractor
supply this weekend me and my wife oh
we'll hear about that we won't
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm
john doloni joined here by
rachel cruz and it looks like on the
debt-free stage
we've got a beautiful couple we've got
jared and stephanie from las cruces new
mexico
and i think i know what this means how
are you two good folks we're doing great
how are you guys doing today
outstanding outstanding all right so
tell us about las cruces
las cruces is a wonderful community that
is
about uh 1400 miles away we drove all
the way here
you drove all the way here how long did
that take you uh it's 20 hours we broke
it up in
a couple days though good for you it was
his birthday on monday so this is his
present
oh for your debt-free scream to be your
present i love it
very cool and so you're here to do your
debt free screen how much have you paid
off
we paid off a hundred forty thousand
four hundred sixty six dollars
hundred and forty thousand four hundred
and sixty six dollars and how long did
it take you
15 months whoa did you sell a house
no no we got thrown a house you just
crushed it okay so
how much what was your income what was
your rate of income during this time so
we started at
188 403 and uh we
increased it to about 206 512. 206 000
512.
are you are you the nerd i am hearing
all these very specific
dollars i was like man i'd be rounding
up
good for you good for you so 188 to 206
that's still a lot of money to pay off
in a year that means you are making an
extraordinary income
and you're still doing rice and beans
right yeah that's right i mean
we we both work in health care and uh i
mean
this last year there's all kinds of work
to be done anyway so we just
we're able to pick up shifts and work
extra wherever that may be
i mean stephanie is a nurse in the icu
so i mean
she picked up an extra 12 hour shift for
about 20 weeks i'd say
wow thank you thank you for your work
though i appreciate that
take us back 15 months what in the world
happened so i'll take it back a couple
years ago i mean about three years ago i
was i'm a pharmacist and i
was doing a pharmacy rotation through
the rural area parts of new mexico and
uh
one part of that was i got to stay with
my uncle during one of those rotations
and
uh he was well into uh dave ramsey stuff
and he
uh kind of he knew that i had a large
chunk of change to pay off
without the salame loan and he's like
you know have you ever really thought
about what you're gonna do
at that point and i i really kind of
brushed him by
for that moment my uncle john and uh
yeah
you know i did i picked up his i picked
up dave ramsey's book the total money
makeover and uh
about maybe six months after that and i
was i was absolutely
hooked right away man that book was fire
man it was just incredible
and uh so about of course um
of course about two years ago my my wife
and i at that time were
not quite married yet but i had
mentioned her kind of the stuff that
i've been reading into and i was kind of
not wholly going into paying off the
debt because i mean
i i was still learning what that was
about and she
she initially was not on page but
we got married and we both put our bank
accounts together and just we're
we're on fire from there you know so
this sounds like the start of a joke
a pharmacist sits down to explain
something to a nurse right
how did that conversation go where you
rolled your eyes and you were like no
um there was a little bit of eye rolling
but we had a few uh road trips to
albuquerque where we listened to the
dave ramsey show together and then i was
kind of hooked after that
um because i got to hear it for myself
but right
a couple days after i got married uh
jaren took me to my bank and used all of
our wedding gift money
and we paid off my credit card so that
was kind of my introduction to what our
marriage was going to be like
all that money that we got from the
wedding was just sent away and she just
was like
i can't believe it so how does it feel
now because you guys started marriage
this whole new way of looking at my i
mean you did it all
at the same time so now you're on this
side of it you've been married a little
over a year
you're debt-free it was just crazy it
was a crazy time
we were dealing with the pandemic like
everyone else trying to figure that out
working working as a nurse through that
was difficult
um and then we were trying to figure out
budgeting for the first time figuring
out marriage for the first time so it
was a lot of firsts for us and it was
difficult but
um we definitely praise god for all the
support that he's given us
and this was all him that's all we
that's what we wanted to say
that's why she was working 12-hour
shifts it's like
i'm good i'll be out i'm going to go do
this so
what kind of debt was this this was
obviously pharmacy school is really
expensive so
student loans what else my student loan
because i had
gotten out of nursing school a while
before that but i was just paying the
minimum payments i thought i would never
be out of debt that was my mindset
until jaren kind of showed me that we
could do something different so
and then a little credit card yeah just
between her yeah mostly
that's a wedding yeah yes took over yeah
that's awesome that's awesome
so what i mean you guys the beautiful
thing about your story is that you're
starting all of this together where we
talked to some couples we just took a
call last segment right and you're
they're together but they're not working
together and they've already created
these kind of money habits in their own
lane so you guys started from the
beginning
so what encouragement do you have for
couples that are dating maybe they're
engaged
to get on the same page like how
important is it do you think to be
one in the subject when you get married
absolutely i mean
you i could not have done this without
stephanie you know this i mean this this
was all
kind of something that i had brought to
her attention but if it had been just me
and not her i mean there's always that
wedge that's always gonna be there and
um and that that that is something that
we didn't want for our marriage we
wanted to go into our marriage knowing
that
um that we we don't have to worry about
the money issue as an issue
if we kept our bank account separate it
would have been a little bit more you
know there's more of a chance of it to
cause an
issue or trouble i mean i mean you
always you guys know the rates of
divorce i mean
yeah that's not something that we wanted
to be in our marriage and we know
um we knew what um what
it said yeah no no no it's right no
you're exactly right and and two
last question with marriage because i
think we we did a thing money and
marriage so this is always fascinating i
love her talking to mary couples about
it because
would you say your your marriage is
stronger
now than it would have been yes i i
think that
the the most important thing a part of
this is i mean there's
a whole grind that goes about being able
to pay off this
debt and um and i i absolutely
lean on stephanie and a lot of the
things that we were able to do but
god oh my gosh like there's times that
you know you're just
watching your your paycheck go straight
towards the government
and it's i mean we're living on much
we're
living on much less than what even
stephanie made and
it's hard it's incredibly hard it's just
um it's just
sometimes i think we're like why why
can't we you know go out to eat like we
used to that's something we really enjoy
and um but i mean when you give it to
god
when you just absolutely just let him
help you handle your finances because we
are his managers it's his money
um it it does get you over that hill and
it's just that extra
boost and that extra stone to lean on
because he's just always there for you
and i just want to add of course it just
runs over into every other aspect of
your life um
so i started um kind of budgeting with
food because i
you know overeating is an easy thing to
do um and i was able to lose 20 pounds
during this wow and then of course um we
started budging our time with god more
like
we need to make sure that we're always
spending time with god every day and so
that's something that we do now too and
we have
grown closer to god to each other um
becomes stronger people
spiritually yeah it's amazing this
finance has nothing to do with it but
we've also grown spiritually because of
our decision right discipline in one
area
it does it trickles through that's
awesome well i'm ready
so we i can't wait i can't wait for
y'all so
paid off 140 466 dollars
in 15 months making between 188 thousand
to 206
000 a better marriage better health
better spiritual life
man they did it jared and stephanie when
you're ready
count it down let's hear it three two
one
oh amazing amazing
i mean incredible can you imagine
driving up to
get your you know driving up to get your
uh
medication and your pharmacist drives up
in an 85 camry
and you think what are you doing and he
says i'm changing everything man
how cool is that doing it all and that's
what i love too because you sometimes
hear about these high-paying jobs and
these high
you know these high earners and they're
just living that they're living to the
very top of what they make
fantasy okay and and they said you know
what we're going to scale down
for one year for a year for 15 months
and it's pretty amazing 15 months and
everything is different
what a great couple yeah no more 12-hour
shifts this is gonna be fun fun fun for
them
thank you for joining us this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm john dolone
joined here with rachel cruz and we are
taking your calls on money
and life triple eight eight two five
five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to mark in washington dc
mark what's going on hey guys thanks for
taking my call um
feel fortunate to be able to talk to you
and actually feel fortunate about the
situation i'm in but
uh first time in my life having a little
bit of extra money is causing me
uh some stress as well so it's not all
uh roses there you go
hey this is this is a good call to take
so what's up man
it's a good call uh here's the picture
i'm 44
um hoping to retire at 60. i'm a wife a
wife and two kids eight and ten
about a hundred thousand in the bank um
seven hundred thousand in retirement
401k step ira hsa brokerage that kind of
thing
i have a pretty good income um over the
past couple of years it's pretty much
uh tripled wow about 350 to 450 yeah
yeah just uh change
jobs still in the same profession but
what do you do man it's a better
compensation
i'm a surgeon okay so you don't mess
around yeah
uh you know i was hoping to get on the
radio soon because i have a case before
clock but
i have a small case i'm gonna be on time
so it's okay you're actually you're
replacing a knee as we talk man
you're you're a talented guy mark so
what's up
um so anyway um yeah so um
the only debt i have med school and i've
been reluctant to pay it down it's at
one point
seven five percent started at about two
hundred thousand i got 120 left
okay mortgage house is about 1.1
and uh down to 550 on that refinance
recently about 2.25 percent that's my
only debt no credit cards no cars
nothing like that
okay so you know recently i came across
a bonus for work
um for 2020 as the last um couple
mentioned you know 2020
terrible in general but for health care
workers it did give us
an opportunity to earn a little bit more
sure so i i came across
a work bonus um about 169
000. and where i'm struggling and i'm
not trying to say i'm in a terrible
situation but i have bouncing around in
my head
you know how much do i keep in the bank
i've never started a 529
how much should i put in a 529 do i do a
457 b
dump it all into a brokerage account do
i look at long-term care so
i'm in that position and i just sort of
can't figure out what what to do
you got it man well thank you so much
number one
in a you keep you keep using very
passive language you just like
we're walking on the street and stumbled
into a bonus my guess is you worked your
butt off in some really scary situations
in a you were there when people were
hurting
and you earned that bonus and i'm
grateful for all the work you
have done and i'm grateful for your wife
holding things together while you've
been
um working like bananas this year so
yeah you earned the bonus
for sure i'm sorry i have worked behind
closed doors with doctors
with their coaching folks through mental
health challenges through relationship
challenges and whatnot
and i'll tell you something that's
always been a mystery to me
is the love affair between a doctor a
medical practitioner
and their student loans you guys
love them you love to hang on to them
and pet them
and sing to them as though y'all are in
love and
here's what i think it is i've got i've
got one person that i i
work with now whose kids are in college
still has his student loans right loves
him deep in his heart right and i we i
give him a hard time about it but it
comes down i think
to looking at this as a math problem
instead of a psychology problem
and so i if i'm you and rachel hop in
here yeah sure
i would take that 165 000 and i would
pay off my
med school before the day is over today
i'd pay it off i would be free from all
of that and then i would start
considering going down
the rabbit hole getting my house paid
off and then moving forward kids called
yeah i was going to ask mark what
what causes you do you relate to what
john just said like what causes you to
keep the 120 around
yeah yeah so i mean it's just the
leverage of the 1.75 percent i i i have
this challenge
you know in my life to uh meet somebody
that has a lower interest rate on their
student debt
yeah and i haven't come across that
person yet you know i'm out of med
school about 20 years
um 30-year loans but i just feel like i
can beat that rate it doesn't weigh on
me
um you know having that having that um
burden
it really doesn't my wife's totally fine
with it
i just feel like i can beat that beat
that rate yes
so i think that like you're saying
you're hitting on the math stuff and you
don't feel like it's weighing on you and
all that and you're in a great position
so honestly you're not losing sleep
at night over this thing you're not
mathematically because it's a small
percentage of everything you have but i
would tell you mark if you paid it
off today and you woke up tomorrow i
guarantee you there is a level
within you spiritually emotionally all
of it that just is gonna
exhale just so just a little bit you may
not even realize it cause you've been
hanging on to it for so long so
what we teach is getting completely out
of debt
first and foremost and so that would
mean yes just going and paying it off
just getting it out of the way
you have cash in the bank you earlier in
the call i wrote it down you have 100
grand what was the hundred grand at the
very beginning of the call
is that cash that you have i know you
have seven hundred and we're talking
about
yeah your hundred dollars just sitting
in a in a you know savings yes that's
great okay
so i want you guys to get and see how
much is six months worth of living of
expenses
for you guys you're in dc so it's
probably gonna be a little bit higher
dollar amount than someone living in
iowa
figure it out what your lifestyle is and
keep that so maybe it's that maybe it's
a less a little more i don't know so
put that aside keep that just boring in
a boring money market account boring
savings account because that's going to
be your liquid emergency fund if
something happens
then i would start to look at your kids
college and their ages again are what
10 and 8 10 so i would set up
yep yes so you may not even qualify
because of your income
for an esa so you may want to look at a
529 plan
and start putting some money away for
their college i think would be the next
best step to look at and then at the
same time
be funding retirement and throw an extra
at that house and because you you have
your house halfway paid off which is
amazing so i mean
you haven't yeah like we said an
incredible situation market i think you
can make a lot of ground financially
if you just stay focused you know you're
doing a couple of things here and there
it's kind of all over but if you just
make these steps and you guys do them
you're going to find progress
financially
so much faster i think than you have
mark what kind of surgeon are you
i'm a cancer surgeon cancer surgeon oh
wow and so is it
are you at on the front end
or are you more in stage 4 acute care
um well you know actually both um as a
cancer as a surgical oncologist
probably about 60 of the surgeries we do
uh the final diagnosis is actually not
cancer
right so you know there's people that
get referred to us so i'm on the front
end but i'm also
you know an everyday sort of sort of
surgeon
working in the office working in the or
so was there a
early on especially march of 2020 march
april may
um the the folks in in in my in my
sphere
just my buddies and folks that i i am
connected to
man they they puckered up the elective
surgeries
overnight right and there were some
folks that were really scratching their
heads about man if we don't open up some
of these low-level things the whole
hospital system rolls over because so
much of our income is based on
come on in were you and was that your
case too
so it's really interesting right so we
shut down for six weeks in april in may
the health system i work for health
system um they announced
they were losing publicly announced they
were losing about 100 million a month
due to the elective surgery
right crisis so there were people there
were places crumbling
sure and we were concerned about um
obviously the health system the patients
we take care of
our own livelihoods um but i don't know
if you're seeing this in your sphere
but what i have seen is now that pain
now that people are home
people want their elective surgeries
because they don't fit this work
so i did more surgeries in 2020 even
with shutting down for six weeks than i
ever had done
any other year in my career uh and that
trend is continuing
yes yes very cool so here here was where
i was where i was aiming
and it rebounded really well for you
which is excellent
the folks that i talked to on the front
end of this deal really got scared
because they thought that that election
that elective surgery
world was over and here's what i'm
getting at if you
even if you have this low interest rate
and yes man you can sit there and
give me a spreadsheet and make the math
work and as a surgical oncologist
that's what you do in your head probably
nobody knows risk like you do nobody can
sit down and say here's probability
here is i'm gonna be the the i'm gonna
walk into this room and i'm gonna make
sure somebody stays alive to tomorrow
that's an extraordinary uh power for
lack of better terms
but i want you to go back to if you've
got no payments you've got no debt
you've got no stress if elective surgery
is
shut off then you can be all about how
do i help other people not how do i
keep from falling apart thank you so
much mark for your service and for your
care man we love you
this has been the ramsay show thanks for
joining us and we'll be back
soon right here
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show where america hangs
out to have a conversation
about your money and your life
i am john deloney joined here by
best-selling author and good human being
rachel cruz and we are taking your calls
on life
and on money triple eight eight two five
five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
rachel how are your little ones doing
they're doing great just
man five three and one five
three and one yes and i've got almost 11
and five you space them out well i feel
like i have a thousand people in my home
and you have
a million and a half oh it's there's a
human everywhere
a human everywhere and one's crying
always but it's great you know it's
great
it is funny though i'm like there's some
days i'm sure every parent feels like
this we were like
man that was like a good like that was a
good day and then sundays you think what
did we do
what are we doing what are we doing the
random thing that my wife will say
she'll walk through house and she'll
just
quietly toss away remember when we used
to think we were busy
i know remember we used to think we were
tired remember that and she'll just keep
walking through the next room it's so
great
i laugh all the time though because i
think i remember so specifically it's
like so in my head
i we had this this lady in college she
like mentored a group of us and where
we'd go to her house and we'd talk and
we just like oh my god i'm so stressed
elizabeth
i have like three exams this week like
i'm like yeah i have a nickel
and she had four kids i looked back and
i'm like her husband worked a lot like
i'm like i just want to call her
oh she probably thought you have no idea
no idea you have no idea when i told my
dad i called him and said hey
listen you're gonna be a grandad
there was no fireworks there was no oh
my son
his response first response was well
you're never going to sleep again
and i remember thinking like that was
kind of deflating me that was the most
prophetic thing i think my dad ever told
me man
well you have good kids though y'all
came over a few weekends ago and had
dinner with us yeah
hank i mean yeah yes they're both
wonderful but hank is just
the sweet i mean talking to charles by
our 16 month old little boy
oh he was like can i feed him when
someone's taken out to bed he's like do
you need help winston like oh yeah so
listen in the car right before we came
in your house we said listen
so sweet to our two kids don't screw
this up for us
for every kind thing you do we're gonna
we're gonna give you fruit loops and
whatever
sugar money
my son was like dad let's just do it
because it's right and my daughter was
like sweet how much
that's awesome all right let's go to the
phones let's go to erica in houston
what's up erica
hi dr john and rachel i'm so grateful to
be talking to y'all and we're grateful
that you called what's up
well i have a what i would consider a
good problem my business has been
extremely busy lately i own a couple
therapy
private practice i can imagine so
and um so i know it's time for me to
expand
into adding some more therapists to come
work for me
um that i would train under me and right
now i have two interns
um but i am still seeing about 80
of the the revenue comes from the
services that i offer
um so i've been having some trouble
finding somebody to hire
and now i've kind of uh i'll call myself
out i've had some really bad boundaries
i've just started taking on
more and more clients uh myself and i
find myself with low
energy to be able to really do much else
other than to see
my clients and write my notes and uh
supervise my interns and that's about it
and so why do you why do you feel like
you have to expand your business
sounds like you love counseling other
people
i do um i also love supervising
and i have another business i would like
to start that would be
separate and so i would like some energy
and time to be able to give to that
and not so much into the clinical work
although i still like to maintain
clinical work
gotcha well i was going to point to you
john because you're you are in this
world i mean
yeah what i find with therapists is they
you get to a point where it's exhausting
right erica you see clients eight hours
a day and it's at weird hours
and it's one of those things where if
you stop and just like hey i'm gonna go
home tonight and have dinner and watch a
tv show
there's that part in your brain that
says well that was 100 bucks right you
can always be working
always moving and then you the next
conversation is what's passive income
look like are we going to write a book
and then you realize there's not a lot
of money in books and i want to create a
curriculum and i want to start work
so yeah and just start explaining so why
do you want to expand things do you want
more money
do you want more um you want more reach
to help more people what's your goal
here
i think it's it's two of those things i
do want more reach to help more people
and be able to offer a variety of
services so that we can treat more
people across the community and then
my other business is also focused on
mental health so minimalism and mental
health and
i'm going to need some time and energy
to be able to put into creating that
content to be able to put that out into
the world
which would also help more people gotcha
are you able to let
other people do their job
under your umbrella differently than you
do it but still effectively
yes i've been working on that because i
did hire a virtual assistant
um not too long ago and so i think
that's given me
some muscles in that although that is
difficult for me
and i would say to erica you can
probably speak into this john because
you're specific
my brother-in-law he's a therapist and
he's
has a wait list all of that i mean like
it's it's insane but people come to see
him
not a practice necessarily right they
want him so how much of your clientele
erica would be okay
to go see someone else like the
percentage in that because i know that
therapy it's such a personal thing right
you you that people want to see you
i know that's why you're so good um what
would it look like to bring on say those
two interns but you make them full time
do you think you'll still have the same
amount of business do people will your
clients feel comfortable going to
someone else
um we've seen some trends in that so
there's still
obviously more people calling for me
once they learn that they're
that the other people are trained under
me most clients are pretty open to that
that's right that transfer of trust
there yeah perfect
so here's what i'd recommend erica i i
would recommend
i just experienced this with my buddies
who are therapists they get so excited
and then they go to a training
and it always comes at a time when
they're exhausted from their day
practice
right they're just hearing the same
married couple fights over and over and
they know what they're doing and they're
good at it
in fact they're excellent at it they're
getting the same calls and they go to a
training and they experience something
new
and they're like i want to do this with
this group of people and i could crank
out this business and i could hire these
people
and then you get a napkin somewhere in a
restaurant and you map it out you
realize
oh we can make this much money and help
this many people
and then you start as as our friend ken
coleman says you
you jump off the dock before the boats
all the way up right and so i'm going to
do two things one
we're going to give you a copy of our
friend christy wright's business
boutique which is going to give you some
actual it's going to help you walk
through the steps of starting a new
business
right you know how to run a business
you're running a successful one but
right now the business
is you and so how do you step away from
this business and then come up with
how do i hire how do i train how do i do
payroll how do i do hr how do i do
training how to do marketing all these
things
while also keeping the practice going
and the second thing is
i want you to take some time to i don't
sound so cheesy i want you to take some
time to dream and
actually paint a picture of what this is
going to look like yeah right what would
a
a friday afternoon look like for you if
your full
your real business is running your
supervision business is running
you've got a group of counselors trained
underneath you and then you're gonna
have to reverse engineer that back and
what do you have to start doing right
now to begin to build that practice
and then you're gonna have to work on
those boundaries and you probably have
to see one of your buddies to help you
with that one erica because that one's a
challenge for all of us who love helping
other people
but i appreciate your question in
houston needs more therapists i'm glad
you're there
don't give up on it hang on the line and
kelly will get you that book
stay tuned this is the ramsay show
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
[Music]
825-5225 taking your calls on money
and life here on the ramsey show let's
go out to charlottesville
virginia and talk to logan what's up
logan how are you doing
hey john hey rachel how are you guys
doing good good good what's up
um so a little debate here between my
fiance and i oh you're gonna drag us
into it huh
we'll be the typewriter absolutely so
we're getting married
uh on may 30th so coming up pretty soon
um and we recently started fpu
um we're feeling pretty good about it
pretty gazelle intense between the two
of us right now we're working
seven jobs and in two weeks from 11
grand in debt to 2 800. so
way to go man yeah
thank you um so and i know this is a
little farther down the line but one of
our goals
um is to purchase a house
with cash within the next 10 years or so
however i was thinking about it and i
think so what she wants to do is just
save up after we get done with baby step
3 go into
3b and save up specifically for the
house
however i think because of how young we
are i think it would be more beneficial
to use that time to open up a roth ira
i'm going to
max that out at 6 000 every year and
then what's left
over after investing into that um
put into either a money market or a
mutual fund to save for a large down
payment on the house
because we're right now i'm 19 and she's
20.
so the yield on that would be a lot
bigger if we start earlier
sure so the debate is save up and pay
cash right away for the house or not
right away it'll take years to save
obviously
or go ahead and take out a mortgage and
continue on is that that's the debate
right
save up and pay cash well no either
either way we wouldn't be
we'd be purchasing the house at the same
time it would just be
do we want to spend these 9 10 years
before we buy
just saving for the house or should we
invest into retirement
and then what's left over after
investing every year put that into a
savings for a large down payment on the
house
but you're saying down payment when you
put it down payment you're taking out a
mortgage though so it's not cash
right right right i'm sorry not not not
i thought you were saying
by now but no would be the same time but
yes yes okay
let me let me make sure i'm
understanding this i'm sorry
so do you take let's say there's a
hundred thousand dollars do you take 50
of that and start investing it now
do you have a hundred thousand dollars
though logan like we're not making that
up
yes but i'm saying but once you get once
you guys pay off your debt
you're gonna save up for that emergency
fund three to six months worth of
expenses
then what we would suggest that you do
if you want to buy a home
then is to save up baby step 3b for a 10
to 20
down payment and then start investing i
would not use baby step 3b
to save cash and not invest in a roth
ira so i'm more on your side on it
i would i would go ahead and keep
putting money away now if you want to
use
it would be baby step 3 right baby step
4 is investing
and if you wanted to say hey we want to
rent for six years
and we're going to save up and write a
check for a house in six years
while we invest you can totally do that
i think that that's a great idea but i
would not miss
out on the investing to save up to pay
cash for a house
does that answer your question okay yes
yeah
i i wouldn't because because like you
said you guys are you guys are young
you have the time a mortgage is the one
type of debt we won't yell at you for so
if you did decide hey we are going to
just do a down payment of 20
go ahead and do the 15-year fixed rate
do the formula to buy a house the right
way
that's great you can do that but if you
guys were kind of
more on the quote-unquote weird side
which we like weird people and say hey
you know we're going to rent a small
apartment
we're going to live on nothing and we
for for eight years we can save up x
amount and pay cash for a house but
we're gonna do that
that's awesome and you've never had a
mortgage in your entire life that would
be that would be great too okay
so either either one of those is totally
is as great
from our book yeah does that answer your
question i'm sorry i know that was a
long way around
but okay no that's fine it does yeah
thank you and logan
um not to oversimplify this but you're
19 she's
20. you all feel like you're 100 years
old right now
and then when you turn 30 you're gonna
feel like man we're really young right
now right
and so it feels like you if you mess
this decision up
it's man you might as well you're not
going to start over your marriage is
going to be off to a sideways start
you all are so far ahead of the average
couple getting ready to get married
yes you you just need to stop and pause
for a second y'all are crushing you're
going to get married in a few months
you're going to be off to the races
and go slow do it together right then
and rachel's right when you when you're
30 you're going to love that you have a
retirement account that you started when
you were 20 21 years old
you're also going to love you got a big
chunk of a down payment or
y'all went ahead and rented for a few
more years and just started your whole
new family tree with no mortgage at all
that's right that's going to be awesome
all right let's go to gary in arlington
gary what is up
hey what's going on doctor d rachel how
you guys doing good good good
what's going on in your world ma'am yeah
so
uh i'm in pharmaceutical sales i'm 27
years old i've paid off about 40k
already in student loan down
nice way to go brother i'm pretty much
debt free
but i got this car situation that i'm
kind of hung up on i have no idea what
to really do
so my parents guided me into this
release of a rav4
after i graduated
oh no gary do you believe i think we
just lost you oh oh there you are you
back
oh yep i'm here guys okay all right so
your parents
talk to you into elise the rav4 yep rav4
um paid off all the lease payments so
now it's like do i
save up this money i got about 15k left
i got about 4k in savings
uh i'm starting to build up my uh
emergency funds
i'm just wondering like should i like
build up and start saving to buy this
car
should i maybe take out a loan pay it
off
sell it take that equity that i have
left and then maybe try to roll that
into a car that's a little bit more
affordable
since i am going to burn this car into
the ground with how many miles i drive
so
i'm just wondering like what i should do
with this car i feel like it's gonna be
a sunken cost if i don't like
just keep on trying to like maybe save
up for it like buy it so
i'm just wondering what you guys thought
yeah and you the 15k
is what was that you said at 15k and
what
uh so the 15k is to buy the car to buy
the car okay i hear you
i hear you yep yep so the lease payments
are done so i'm just like
what do i do with this like i feel like
i almost have a part of this car but
it's like
i would just kind of hate myself if i
just like gave it up i would have to pay
the mileage overage that i'm currently
accumulating with this job
how much is that how much is the mileage
over
so i just passed it not too long ago
with that so
the cap was at 36 i'm at like 38 right
now it's
i think it's like 25 cents a mile for
21.
2021 you've already kept past the cap
oh no this is a 2018 rav4 no no but i'm
asking you
are you talking about for the year
you've already passed your cap
or for the the amount of the latest the
arc of the lease
so over the three years i was given 12k
mileage per year um and i've already
passed that
like i'm past the 36k that that's been
allotted for the lease
so you're out so the lease is the lease
is the lease is done correct
lease is done these payments are done i
would i would need until the end of this
year and that's when the lease is
secondly up and that's why i need to
make a decision am i buying this car am
i going to turn it in
yeah should i buy and sell it yeah if
you don't if you uh gary if if i didn't
have the cash to go ahead and buy it
whatever that if
if it's that 15 grand or less at the end
of the year depending on lease payments
i wouldn't buy it i would i would be
done with it
even though you kind of take the hit and
then just start over
chalk that up as a mistake and then go
pay cash for another car
because that's good okay cheaper than 15
grand
what's your penalty going to be do you
know
uh well if i keep on driving it like the
that 25 cents a mile is just going to
start cueing a accruing that's just
going to
be ridiculous i think at the end of the
year yeah so like that's why i'm trying
to like
kind of like what should i do with this
car like do you guys think like taking
out a loan
and then like trying to sell it and then
pay back the loan
immediately once i sell the car and then
do it
no it's kind of like not like yeah no
i wouldn't advise that because the only
time i would take out a loan is if you
were upside down in the car
not through a car lease but a car alone
you're trying to pay the gap off and get
out of
that yeah so i i would get out of the
lease as soon as possible gary if that's
at the end of the year do it and then
just scratch it up to stupid tax that's
what we call it around here
and so you would pay that off and then
go buy a car that's going to get you
yeah
that's going to let you use this car
because you're going to run into the
ground anyways you don't need a brand
new one
yep yeah i hope that helps gary
sorry that's an expensive lap upside the
head huh
that yes don't get a lease with a
mileage cap if you're in a
job that requires you to try to be a
traveling salesman
come on parents you got it gary you can
do it though
i believe in you because it's a good
clap this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
825-5225 taking your calls on money
and life let's go to justin in new york
city justin what's going on
[Music]
hi guys uh nice to speak with you um
i've been listening to
dave for a long time and i've been
focusing on my family
my wife and myself and our income and
getting our debts taken care of and such
but it took me a while to realize that
my in-laws have
been failing on their own and um i'm
trying to get them to
move out of their home and downsize to a
smaller house
um and having that conversation hasn't
been going so well
um and you know my brother-in-law's been
giving them money
to take care of the mortgage for a while
and they just they can't afford the
house they live in
yeah they do have equity in it and i'm
trying to get them to sell
and cash out and then downsize i wanted
to get your opinion on
how to go about what's their reasoning
justin
to stay in the home that they can't
afford and they're having to take money
from their
son to pay their mortgage
i don't quite understand all of it but
it's it's you know they've been in the
house for 25 years
okay they've come to live in that
lifestyle
and downsizing just i guess
they think they'll be looked down upon i
guess it's a hurt to their ego it's like
a kind of a little bit of an equal
correct correction not enough of an ego
hit that they're going to take money
from their children
to cert keep this mirage that's what i'm
saying yeah
so this is going to be hard to hear i
don't get it
yeah and that's here's the thing there's
nothing you can do man
um you can i say nothing you can you can
force the bottom
you can be a kind person you can have
this
one hard conversation where you are
respectful and you treat them with
dignity
and you you take a more
curious route hey tell me about what
what the plan is moving forward
you're working on your legacy with their
daughter and with whatever family you
are going to have
it can become a curiosity thing but man
you can't walk in and make anybody do
anything
and as you know this isn't a math
problem when grown people start taking
money for their
from their kids not for food but for a
fantasy
man we have left the the
the cognitive reasoning area right
that that ship has sailed yeah
absolutely i mean that that's it justin
i mean it's kind of a
it's a it's a hard answer to your
question which is how do i convince
my in-laws that they need to downsize
you can't convince them i mean
i think that you can be a place to say
you you and your wife can choose not to
enable that behavior so if their son
can't afford it gets to a point where he
can't afford the house payment
you guys can set a very clear boundary
that we're not going to help you fund
this lifestyle and we're
we will not be that back up i mean
there's things you know that you
and your wife can have together to know
this is how we're going to do our life
in our marriage
um versus how they're doing it but yeah
there
there is no convincing unless they're
asking questions and want to know
so justin have you sat down with your
brother-in-law
and talked to him about his enabling of
of their lifestyle
yeah i've been having that conversation
as recently and uh
he gets it and he understands but i
don't know if he's a
assertive enough to um you know
really go hard and cut them off yeah to
kind of direct them in the direction
they need to go well i think for you
justin if there's
one more thing you can do just for your
own self
and tell me you're the therapist over
there but i mean for you
because you and your wife i'm sure are
concerned and you hate this for them
because it's eating up their money
they're having to take money for me it's
just not it's not a good situation
so for you too because it's it's her
parents it's not your parents
so both of you or even just her to say
hey mom and dad and it's the last
conversation we're gonna have about it
but for myself
i just need to say out loud i'm
concerned about you guys
i hate that this is where life has taken
you and i just
i see the writing on the wall and i feel
like you would have a better quality of
life if this house wasn't sucking the
life out of you and you're having you
can't afford it
so as your daughter that's what i see
whether you choose to take that or not
i just need to say that for myself and
then that's it like
i don't know yeah and at the end of the
day anything you carry with you justin
and it's going to be hard for you to
hear
is a choice to make your day worse is a
choice to make your marriage have
conflict in it because you can't do
anything about that conflict
like rachel said you and your wife can
talk about
how firm your boundaries are going to be
not if but when they come knocking on
your door for money
how firm your boundaries are going to be
if and when they lose this house because
they run out of money
and they're going to have to move in
with you y'all can have those
conversations now
but man there's no sense in just beating
your head against the wall it's not
going to change
it's frustrating and parents
don't rob your kids of their legacy
because you're living in a fantasy world
don't do that to your children
if it if you need money for food if you
need money for
medical care yeah you call your family
if you think wow
we got this really big house and it's
important to us because we feel don't do
that to your legacy
come on all right let's go to tj in
nampa tj what's going
all right on you rachel thanks for
choosing my call i appreciate it
you got it man thanks for calling in
what's up
uh well i just want i need a little bit
further advice on uh what next to target
on our debt snowball here
you've got a genius sitting next to me
so you called the right place brother so
what's up
well um wife and i of course uh didn't
uh
do the smart things we were actually
pretty dumb early on and
took out a bunch of student loans going
to college and after we both
graduated we're done with school uh here
we are we ended up with uh
combined between the two of us we got
just over 100k
in uh student loan debt we rised up
after we had a shocker when
uh there was a kind of a family event
that happened and it forced us to move
back in with my folks
for about three years but during that
time we paid off all of our
unsecured debt other than uh
just the student loans and now we've
finally started to climb back towards
solvency and we got the house that we've
been in for about three years we just
recently refinanced it
to get it down to a fixed uh 20-year it
was on a 30-year variable
and we owe about 140 on it right now
payment on the house is just over 9.30
payment on the
student loans right now most of them are
ibr and the rest is
some total about 220 but that's not even
enough to cover interest on the
on the loan
and so your question tj is which one to
pay off you're asking the student loan
or the house
right because we're to the point now our
vehicles are paid off
our credit cards are paid off we finally
got smart and
and buckled down paid off about 14 000
in credit card good for you guys thank
you and then we also paid off both
uh vehicles um but now we're just to the
point where we want to know what to
tackle next
um if we tackle the house it's not much
more as far as the the balance
but the the strain on the budget is much
greater
i hear that yeah it might help us to
snowball the
the student loans on the other hand the
student loans
the interest is killing us it's actually
the balances have gone up this year over
the last even with our payments
yep i hear you well i'm going to stick
to our rule of thumb
which is paying off all of your debt at
your house and so that student loan it's
the last one
and it's the hardest mathematically it's
the hardest mentally because it is a
mountain to climb right you like you
guys killed fourteen thousand dollars in
credit card debt okay
a hundred grand is a lot so is that
hundred grand
how many are there are there multiple
loans within that number i'm assuming
yeah there's about uh age of ten okay
so what i would do tj because there's
almost a mental game to this we always
talk to people about when you're paying
off debt
that you need that momentum right and
you guys kind of felt that i could hear
your voice yeah we paid off fourteen
thousand dollars in credit cards
like you couldn't feel it so on a sheet
of paper
i i would i would map out i would break
out that hundred grand so instead of
trying to tackle everest
you kind of have these little these
hills right that you're working towards
and that's going to continue guys on so
i i would
for sure tackle the student loan debt
and if you can break it up even just for
your own sanity
i feel like that that would be helpful
as well when we had my wife and i had
six figures of student loans we
this sounds so cheesy but we made little
little chains
yeah and they were of the little loans
right and
every time we got one every month we
would tear one off and some
months i would just sit there and we
actually hug it in our bedroom how's
that first that's real man
heavy uh bedroom decor sheila was like
thank you joe thanks man
all i wanted no john you really just
know how to doll up a room but
it so much you sit there and see it and
it just ah
but you never forget it right and then
it's smaller smaller
and yeah but it's just biting that
elephant one eating that elephant one
bite at a time that's right
oh man thanks for that call tj just keep
plugging away
little steps little steps little steps
you got this you got this you got this
we'll be right back this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
825-5225 this is the ramsay show i'm
john deloney joined here with
best-selling author rachel cruz taking
your calls on life
and money let's go to chilo in los
angeles california chilo what's up
hello how are you doing today
outstanding how are you
good good i had a question i have um my
daughter who's
about to turn 19 uh this month um she
has two thousand
two thousand dollars put away and she
hasn't had an investor and i have no
idea
how to tell her how to invest it
um so i'm wondering if i can get guided
or some advice on
how to help with that because i don't
want to steer in the wrong direction
what's her name her name is camila
oh beautiful beautiful beautiful okay so
considering her age she's 19.
our advice usually for young people
around this age is
it's going to sound cheesy but it's just
true the best investment
is in themselves and so i think at a
young age
depending upon what's her education like
is she going to go to
a four-year school is she going to
university or is she going to the
workforce
she's not sure yet what she wants to do
if she wants to go to school if she
wants to go to straight school
she got really um that's what i'm
looking for she basically got
in covet hit it really rocked her she
was supposed to graduate she wasn't able
to walk her right yeah
so she's kind of like in a funk so to
speak right now
yeah for sure um you know she's working
um
doing housekeeping um with her
uh mother's boyfriend and the two
thousand dollars that she has she
actually got it from uh that pandemic
money that california was offering and
so she hasn't touched it she said
i don't want to touch it i don't know
what to do with it but i know i want to
invest it
yeah so um right now you know schools
are really going to be opening back up
so she doesn't know if she's going to be
going to
college or trade school just work
full-time that's great well
well i'll tell you my advice would be if
she called me today i would say
two grands at her age and with
the her seasons of life changing so much
right now that she doesn't really have a
firm plan
the best thing is just to keep it with
cash and a really boring
savings account or a money market
account right now um
because number one she may need that
money if she chooses to go to school to
help her with tuition
she may need that money if she wants to
go into the workforce and get an
apartment
and start i mean two grand in the grand
scheme of things right can can be a
pretty good boost for that 19 year old
so
because when i when i think about
investing investing for me is long
term which means five years or more and
while it's great mathematically to start
as young as possible again
having that cash available during all
these random transitions that she's
going to be occurring in the next
probably five years of her life
having some cash to spare is a real is a
huge blessing i mean that's huge so
i would relay to her hey i wouldn't put
it in the market right now
even though what you're thinking about
is so good like the fact she's even
thinking about investing at 19
props to her you have a very smart
daughter i was not but i
yeah so yeah she's way different than
that for sure great and i think that's
awesome and i would and encourage that
in her
like that she's so smart that's so good
but i would have it
available for me at 19 to use during
this transition period and then once
she's out of school or if she goes to
trade school or she goes right into the
workforce and she has a little bit of a
steady
um a steady stream of a season of life
that she sees and she says okay
now i'm gonna work to see if i can use
this if she has any debt to pay it off
or to keep it for a fully funded
emergency fund
and then look into retirement so even
though it's great to start early
mathematically speaking it's much better
to have cash available
at 19. i can't even tell you i think i
would smile for a month if my 19 year
old was like hey dad i got 2 000 bucks
that would make me smile
and on top of that would be i'm thinking
for the future dad
it's just it's awesome i married well
because that didn't come from me
all right daniel in orlando what's up
hey i just have a couple of i guess a
multi-part question
all right go for it we we're in are just
coming out of baby step
two uh where credit cards are paid off
cars
we're right at the should have those
paid off at the end of this month
congratulations brother and then the
only thing appreciate it the only thing
left is our mortgage that's
first part second part is we own our
own business um and we do have a
business loan and we use credit cards at
the business
i mean i know even though we pay them
off we
we're looking at dropping those and just
going like dave says going with the
debit cards um but i i'm
trying to figure out how to move forward
if we stuck to
what we're doing now we could probably
have our home paid off by the end of
this year
but i don't know if i should just go
into
the fifteen percent or do them all
simultaneous
i guess as far as retirement goes how
much
is your business loan
probably close to about eighty thousand
eighty thousand how much how much you
have left on your mortgage
about 137. okay
well technically with business debt i
mean it is still
your debt right your name's on it you're
responsible for it and that's the
conversation me and my wife were happy
totally so i yeah that's right so
i would go ahead and pay off the
business loan um
okay because you said you'll be able to
pay off your mortgage this year which
means you're going to have 80 grand this
year to pay off that business loan
so i would go ahead and relieve myself
of that um
and then start looking at retirement
like you said you're 15
um past that and then just kind of chip
away at the house
um but that's that's the order i would
do because the hard thing with business
debt again i feel like people function
with two sides of their brain almost
they can like split it down the middle
and say well that's my business side and
this is my personal
but it's still you like you still owe
the money right you still haven't so
that's the conversation my wife yeah
it's a great and it's a great
conversation
it's personal i mean it i mean it's
still guaranteed by me
right exactly exactly that's right yeah
we're still guaranteeing yet which
which kind of stinks in a way because at
least if you're paying off your house
it's like
you have a paid for asset for you
personally it feels so personal
where the business again feels like this
other part of your life but it is your
life so
i'd go ahead and pay off the business
alone if i were you daniel and with that
kind of that kind of income
you're you're almost you're flipping it
right so two years from now you're gonna
have a paid off house yeah you're
gonna have a debt-free business right
and then you can start building up the
business emergency fund your homework
fund that's fantastic that's right
that's right
have you ever made a dumb decision with
zeros on the end because you didn't do
your research
me too rachel probably has it i have
most people make choices based on
feelings or opinions especially when
they're buying a house
people fall in love with the houses
though it's a person right but when it
comes to the real estate market feelings
are not your friend
facts are so check your facts find out
what you can actually afford
research trending in home research
what's trending in home prices
talk to a reputable real estate person
in
your area never buy a house without the
facts again text
house to 33789 and get an agent who will
help you make smart decisions
that's house to three three seven
eight nine listen rachel i used a
ramsay real estate elp
it was incredible and here's why i come
from texas where you know
they ask for 150 000 for a house and you
say
i'll give you 110 and they're like pew
pew pew how about 140 right and we all
shake hands in the middle
in nashville that same house is 11
million dollars
and they expect you to give a million
dollars over the asking yeah 12 million
actually
and write me a letter and i want you to
sing a song on our front porch
and um we go ahead and invest in my
child's retirement account i mean it's
like bananas
so i had the first few houses we put
offers on
now i feel like an idiot and my
real estate agent i'm a little bit loud
and
demonstrative and i'm like john
my elp she called and said we need to
have a talk about
um your expectations and about reality
and rachel her name's amanda she is
incredible she let me have it in the
most professional awesome way
totally recalibrated my brain kept my
marriage intact i think
and we ended up in an awesome house that
took too long to buy because the
national markets bananas but
having that person who was trained and a
person of integrity and who knew the
market sideways and forwards and would
say
this is a bad offer we're not doing this
right and would say hey this is a really
good deal this is what you're looking
for let's go for it yeah yep
so good that's the thing about i feel
like when it comes to our life these
parts of our lives that can be
complicated
and kind of intimidating if there's
people that work in them day in and day
out
use it like like let them do it have a
professional in your backpack at all
times
it's awesome for sure hey another hour
in the books thank you so much rachel
thank you james and kelly and bobby
bobertson
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm john deloney joined
here with my good friend and
best-selling author
rachel cruz and we are taking calls
about your relationships and your money
and your mental health and
everything going on in your life give us
a shout triple eight eight two five five
two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five
let's jump to the phones let's talk to
jennifer in tampa florida jennifer
what's going on
hi thank you so much for taking my call
how are you guys we are outstanding
thank you so much for giving us a shout
so what's up
so here's the back story my husband and
i make 140 000
we are saving for retirement second baby
on the way
have a college fund for our first child
we have about twenty thousand dollars in
the bank
um we have fifteen thousand dollar
emergency fund
baby step six um we have 75 000
in a single stack um and our question is
we're wondering if we should invest
in the stock market or if we should pay
off our house
we have 200 000 left on our mortgage
um the only issue is we know that we're
probably going to want to move within
the next five to 10 years
um not guaranteed but we know that we
would like to move
this isn't we don't believe in a forever
house but we don't think this is
our long-term house gotcha well y'all
are crushing it congratulations
we are we're very black we've been
listening dave ramsey for a while
that's so great so you're wondering if
you need to pay off the house
yeah should we pay off the house should
we
save um cash for our next house
um what is the single stock we want we
don't have to move
i'm sorry what's the single stock that
the 75 000
is sitting in is it work related stock
is it is it stock available from your
company or is it you just guys wouldn't
bought
a bunch of a stock it was um it was it
was the company my husband used to work
for okay
anymore okay okay and what other
retirement do you guys have jennifer
um we're doing 15 you are currently
doing 15. we have four
yep we have 401k okay so you're doing
that okay so
what amount of money are you wondering
about are you worried about the 75 000
that's in the
that's in the uh single stock or the 20
grand that's in the savings account just
sitting there that's not the emergency
funds all of that so i mean you got
about a yeah
about 100 grand yeah we're wondering
should we take out the stocks
um and it's been about 10 years
um since we've had that okay um
and we have our emergency fund we have
20 thousand dollars in the bank we also
transferred
another 20 000 that's in a separate
account that we're
putting that towards the house every
month wow so should we just throw that
all on the mortgage
so i guess we have forty thousand
dollars in the emergency stop the
emergency fund yeah that's great
good for you guys yeah well obviously
yeah
yeah so from the emergency fund oh
separate yes well obviously keep that
emergency fund the 15 grand that you
said i'm assuming that's
your three to six months of expenses
leaving that cash in the bank
and then everything else combined that
that forty thousand dollars in savings i
would cut yeah that that single stock i
wouldn't keep in especially since it's a
company doesn't work for anymore and
it's
sort of a different story if you want to
buy into the company you're in all of
that but
you guys are out of that so i would take
that out and
i mean you could you could hit that
house real hard
jennifer i mean you could you could pay
off half the mortgage
with just that cash um and how old are
you guys
we're 32. 32. yeah so you have you have
time for retirement and you guys are
still funding 15
which is awesome i would i would
continue that 15
out of your 140 income and then i would
take some of this and just throw it at
the house jennifer because if you guys
how young you are i mean if you guys get
to 36 with a paid for home
retirement just going i mean you're in a
real good spot
and i would yeah well i guess go ahead i
guess our only problem is
that we think that we don't know but we
think we might move within the next five
to ten years oh that's right you said
that pay off the house
that's kind of our concern so here's if
i go back five years
that's three jobs in two states ago for
me that i didn't see coming
if i go back 10 years it's actually for
us too that's even more right so
it's good to have this dream on the
whole like depending on the ups and
downs of the real estate market you're
not gonna this money's not just gonna
evaporate on you
on the opposite side you're gonna have
no house payment two young kids you're
gonna be able to
be a lot more flexible with whatever
comes your way
so i'm with rachel man i would pay this
house off asap and you were
way down the road on that i would
definitely sell that single stock yeah
and even even though you guys may be
moving
you have a paid for house i mean all
that equity it's not like that money's
going on the drain i mean that's
you pay for a house so when you when you
sell you get all the money you get all
that i mean
you get that money it's there yeah so so
yep that's what we would do
thanks jennifer off that's so good man
all right let's go to ashley
in jacksonville ashley how's it going
what's going good how are you good good
good how can we help
yeah so i graduated with my bachelor's
degree with zero debt and
i'm currently planning to start grad
school in the fall
in january i'm actually looking at
either
english or humanities i'm looking at a
career in academia so i'm trying to
figure out where exactly i want to
position myself
gotcha so
in january i bought a car and
put half down finance the rest that's my
first and only debt um
so i currently have thirty thousand
dollars uh in savings
to cash flow grad school
awesome and i'm wondering right now is
it a smart idea to go ahead and just
completely kill the car loan and
pay that off um before i start grad
school or
or should i kind of put that through how
much do you have left on the car
about ten thousand ten grand okay
um yeah i would go ahead and tackle the
car
um because grad school you're gonna have
obviously it's
it's very expensive but you have time
chunks of time right to
to pay it as you go um
where if you get this car out of the way
that debt all your income can go
towards aka investing in yourself
actually i mean putting that money
towards grad school to continue afloat
um which i believe you can do because
like you went through undergrad
which you're crazy weird right now yeah
you you're without them
how did you do that ashley people are
wondering that because everyone
graduates with student loans everyone
does that's normal
how'd you do it yeah yeah so
i had really great supportive parents uh
so
um i lived with them um for the first uh
adventure school i actually went to the
uh to community college i got two
associate degrees
through there and worked through school
so i was paying as i went
i also was able to get a pretty good gpa
so i got a scholarship to go
to university and i actually was able to
finish up university in only three
semesters because i had done so much
uh through the community college and
your degree is from the university that
you wanted and you paid
very correction of it because of what
you did ashley you're so smart
so smart well done well done pay that
car off and before my mom is an english
professor
those jobs are hard to come by these
days so before you go to grad school
sit down with a person who works in that
field
and get some real life
information about what that lifestyle is
like what the what the money on that
life is going to be and what the day to
day is going to be it's usually
different than people thinking the roi
it's a hard life beautiful we need good
english professors but it's tough
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had chm chm saved our life
same doctor financial life christian
healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance but it is a
budget friendly option
and the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
825-5225 this is the ramsey show
i'm john dalone joined here with rachel
cruz ramsey personality
taking your calls on life and money
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one
online retailer of custom window
covering you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run
every month you'll save even more
use promo code ramsey to get the best
deal
rules and restrictions apply rachel
today's question comes from herbert new
york i'm a history professor at an
expensive private university
students from my department will most
likely not go on to make a six-figure
income
as most of them want to teach part of my
job is to recruit students into my
my department but i cannot in good
conscience tell them
to take out loans i know most of them do
because they couldn't afford
private tuition otherwise what do i say
to students to get them
to my department but at the same time
being realistic
realistic that my major is maybe not the
best thing for their financial future
that's a hard one john what do you think
oh man
that's hard for this particular person
um yeah the values of their institution
the values of the place that that pays
for their paycheck
is not in line with the values that sit
on his pillow every night
and one of the questions i would have if
herb is just hanging out here and we
have a cup of coffee and he's asking me
the same question
it would go deeper than that for me
because he's doing a good job of
distancing himself from this issue and
making it a moral and ethical issue
for them not for him the reality is
his business is supported by
something he didn't believe in so it's
not so much as
it's it you can flip this around right
he doesn't want students to go into debt
and he's having a hard time encouraging
them to take on debt to get a degree
that he knows they're going to struggle
to pay back
yep but deeper than that where i want to
charge her challenge herb is
you're taking a salary from a company
that doesn't align with your values and
he's got a hard question
he's taking care of these students but
he's not really getting to the root of
the question
yep which is do i believe in where i
even work
and we we've taken calls on this show
like hey i
wanted to work in finance my whole life
my whole life and i got my first job out
of college at a local bank
and all i'm doing is selling loans right
and i spent all this time getting out of
debt and i don't think i can keep doing
this
right yeah and so i think everybody
everybody has to have that hard
conversation
does what put food on my table align
with my values
yep and you don't always have to go
running for the hills right
like i gotta quit today and i'm gonna
sure sure sure
but i do think that's a worthy
conversation to have herb i'm gonna tell
you
i know a number of people i've had this
exact conversation with a number of my
friends across the united states
some of them have said i've got to get
out of working higher ed i can't keep
doing this
some have made a transition from this
from a private
you know um expensive private school to
a community college
some of them have just said man this is
what it is what it is right the students
are grown-ups they can choose to make
this
decision on their own and we're going to
keep blown ahead the value proposition
is different from everybody but man
herb you're not gonna be able to sleep
i'm telling you right now based on that
question yeah
what do you recommend to folks who are
balancing yeah
i don't i don't believe in where i work
anymore
because it's a complete it's a complete
mind shift right
yeah from what you saw was okay and
normal to suddenly realizing in probably
his own life
oh wow i don't i hate dead i'm going to
get out well and now i'm here
ushering a new generation a generation
right into it
knowing that they're going to get jobs
that aren't going to even support
them financially to pay off the debt
like well and if you're any kind of
professor
who obviously herb's good at what he
does just because of this this
the the depth of this question you talk
to students all day long
and you hear what's on their heart mind
and what's number one on their heart and
mind is
i'm never gonna be able to pay this back
ever i'm never gonna be able to pay this
back so this is probably a bigger
question that you can answer but you
worked kind of in the sector in life
like you've
for a long time yeah you've been a part
of it so how do we
and again it's a bigger conversation but
prop the next generation and say yes
education is good and we need people in
all these fields right like the last
call we just took was about an english
professor
uh his wasn't it yeah about one to be an
english professor yeah yes and all of
that in the roi and
yes uh going to school and grad school
and all that and you mentioned yeah just
make sure you talk to someone that's
been in that world so you know
so like how do we keep all of that
because we need that in our society like
we need
english professors we need people that
are getting degrees
in fields that are not supported
financially you know what i'm saying
the degree is so expensive like it's
just it feels like a
not a lost cause but it's defeating it's
it's sitting in our seat because i'm
like man
you believe in all that stuff and you
and you love the people in those
institutions and they're great but it
just feels like it's broken
yeah i i think that's what it comes down
to is i am i am somebody who
believes deeply that we have let go
the arts we have let go english we have
let go the ability to read and discern
some of these problems we're having
now writers have been writing on the
stuff for hundreds if not thousands of
years right
but we don't teach history anymore we
don't teach them these things anymore
because it's all about roi what's the
roi on this job we get a coding job
so i think we lose something i really
really do yeah
and you can't charge a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
for for a job it's it's a better you're
gonna make forty thousand dollars
right you can't do that um i think it's
both and i think
everybody in this conversation has to
put on the table sure and i will say i
i know a number of higher ed leaders are
trying to fix it from inside out
i know a number of tech companies that
are trying to solve it from the outside
and we all got a great lesson this last
year
man just throwing everything online
isn't going to solve it either that has
been miserable
and we also learned a lot how can you
make online learning better because it
could be cheaper but you're right it's a
mess yeah right and we need some
grown-ups to stop acting like kids and
actually say we're gonna
be a part of some of these solutions and
there's some
really bold higher ed leaders who are
making some major changes there are some
bold
tech folks who are weighing in so i
think we're going to see some
significant shifts
and i hope hope hope for the sake of our
kids it's not at the expense of
reading and history right in music but
it's at the expense of
man it's not a four-year vacation
anymore yeah right that's right that was
a moment that's what's wild is that the
four-year
institution college as what we knew when
we went
probably like it is what it is it was
affordable you could you know i mean all
of it i mean and not that you can't
still go to school
debt free we just got a call from
someone that did you can figure it out
you can do it yeah
but it's uh it is shifted and bring in
2020
when most of the universities were
closed and it was online
figured out yeah it's just i mean it's
it's wow we don't have
a solution if eight if however many
millions of 18 year olds just hit the
job market tomorrow in 1982
we can't absorb that either right so
it's not as simple as close all the
collet that's a bad decision sure
sure sure and so yeah it's going to take
some leadership
which is the key here and some people
being really honest about what
tomorrow's going to look like and some
people not getting what they want et
cetera et cetera
and that brings us back to her you're
gonna have to have a hard conversation
with the mirror my brother
and not only about these students you're
gonna have to
have a hard conversation about where it
does your income
come from do you align with the values
of where you
where you draw a paycheck from and can
you do what your job asks you to do and
if your job is asking you
to do something that violates your core
value system you gotta find a job man
yeah you got to
and that's not higher just higher
education that is that's absolutely yeah
every
job you're listening yep that's it or
you work at a gas station and you get a
new manager that asks you to do stuff
right it's like it's everywhere you got
to have those core set of values and say
this is where my line is yes right
yes which is part of knowing yourself
and that's a lot of the stuff you talk
about
you got to know yourself is the
self-awareness of that i mean like it's
it's huge understanding why you do the
things you do
that's right and and and where you come
yeah you talk about it too i think all
of us
distilled down to this idea of you've
got to be intentional yeah gotta be
intentional that's right all right russ
let's uh russell let's go to russell i'm
just going to say russell about eight
times here russell in virginia beach
what's up russell how are we doing
hey how are y'all today i appreciate you
taking my call oh hey brother
listen i messed up the clock here hang
on here and we're gonna roll you over
and we'll get you right after this break
i should have just kept talking for a
second i tried to i tried to extend this
a little bit john
i'm not gonna lie i thought well i talk
about self-awareness
we talk about self-awareness we'll get
there
we'll come to you soon we'll be right
back russell this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
825-5225 we're taking your calls on life
and money i'm john dalone joined by
rachel cruz
we're going back to russell in virginia
beach
russell what's going on brother
russell are you there my man yeah i'm
here
one of the key things about uh answering
the phone is actually picking it up so
sorry about that so what's up man we're
definitely here hey i'm seeking some
advice today
go for them i'm quickly approaching
about 35 years of service in the navy
oh thank you congratulations man yeah
thanks i appreciate that it's been an
awesome experience so i recently bought
a home when we transferred back to
virginia
um the home was about a half million
bucks
and my wife and i have no credit card or
car loans the home is really it and so
we've done pretty well we've got about
400 in mutual funds
which we continue to invest in we've got
another
roughly 230 between roth ira off psp
and continue to contribute to that we've
got about 115
in cash so my question is
is it a smart move knowing that i'm
going into retirement at least from the
military
um and to take a large chunk of money
say 300
000 out of my mutual funds to put on the
house
which would allow me to pay the house
off by like 20 29.
if you pulled out the three how much do
you owe on the house total today
490. 4.90 okay now all the mutual funds
you just rattled off a lot of them were
roth so are they all
retirement specific mutual funds no no
no the
the 400 of it is just mutual funds oh
it's just a mutual fund okay so no
penalties if you cash that out
there's no retirement penalties there no
it's just tax right yep yep
um yeah i mean russell if i were you
if you if you wanted to take a chunk and
throw it at the house
because your other retirement i mean you
have some other retirement the ones you
you just named yeah my first year out of
service
uh my retirement will be eighty thousand
take them
okay yes
i i would if i were you um again i would
not take out for those listening i would
not cash out retirement
in order to pay off them no i wasn't
planning on touching that though yeah
exactly but the mutual fund i mean you
have 400 in it
yeah you could take a chunk of it and
throw it at the house because a goal
um obviously is to pay off the home
and to be able to you'll be getting that
80 grand um
from your service and you'll you have
these other these other vehicles
for retirement which you can live off of
as well so i'm gonna pay for close to
paid for
paid for home in that big time is is
huge
so russell i'm i'm uh curious
30 years in the service
and now you think yeah you're
transitioning out to become a civilian
what are you gonna do
that's the million-dollar question i
have some ideas
i have a side hustle i breed snakes uh
so that's what hey that's what my little
brother does my brother does that too
yep i've been doing it for about 20
years okay what kind of snakes russell
i want to know how to make a lot of
money but it brings in about 20 a year
yeah wow that's a pretty good gig
do you use real my live mice or frozen
ones
frozen there you go that's a true
breeder right there
we could really get off the rails on
this conversation russell i like you
we could we could but yeah
go ahead go ahead i was gonna say i i
i'm
a hundred percent with rachel i love the
idea of
you having that great military pension
which you've earned every penny of
and having a paid for house or really
close to paid for a house
and um man getting this jet set off
whatever the rest of your life's gonna
be
having the greatest reptile sale
online salesman in the country man
russell the snake man i love it
all right let's go to maggie in san
diego maggie what's going on
uh hi thank you for taking my call i'm
new to the program
so i'm just starting off in the baby
steps i'm on number two
to our band of weirdos maggie we're glad
that you're here
thank you thank you um so i moved in
with my aunt to be her full-time
caregiver
and three years ago she put my name on
her unless we did a grant deed
but now i'm debating if i should sell my
house
since those prices are skyrocketing
right now in order to pay off her house
as well as
pay off the rest of my debt and if i
keep
the house that my house i could use it
as an
investment you know later on down the
line and have that as a secure
monthly income but if i sell it off now
that's like a quick
way to kind of get ahead sure
um maggie how much debt do you have that
you want to pay off
um the only that i have is my car
payments for my kids and that's about
28 000. 28 000 car payments for your
kids why aren't they paying their own
car payment
uh well i i did make some problems to my
kids before they went off to college
that i'd buy them my car so they
wouldn't have to worry about
transportation
so uh you know i'm still making the
payments on them all right that's
another phone call
that's another phone call um maggie
so you have those car payments 28 grand
and that's it
except for your aunt's home that you are
on now on the deed
of and how much is the home
her house is there's probably about a
hundred and
thirty thousand left on her house on my
house
um that i'm not even living in right now
my husband just there pretty much by
himself
um is about two hundred and eighty
thousand left that we along that
two hundred and how much how much is it
worth how much equity would you get from
it
it's worth about six hundred thousand oh
wow okay
and how much is your aunt's house worth
about 550 something like that 500 okay
and so your husband is in your home yeah
so does he want to move in with your
aunt
is he is he on board with this well he
doesn't want to but he's going to help
you
well played well played that sounds like
i should probably have a breakfast
together and talk about this
uh what what is that what's the plan
here for
are you is your is your aunt terminal
are you planning on
taking over the home after she can have
to move to a
care at some point to skilled nursing or
something
we're going to take care of her here
because i'm already i am a nurse so
she'll get the best care for me so is
there any other family drama that
doesn't
like this that are sending you mean
notes about it or is everybody happy
that hey
you take the house you take ant and
we're going to move on
yes sir everyone's okay with i mean they
know i'm the closest one too that's why
she couldn't uh
she did a grant b when her husband died
so we wouldn't have a problem with it
okay it's been i i i i don't i
my my hesitation maggie is you putting
your money on a home
that you're that the deed is split so
it's not your entire home it is
her home so that feels a little messy to
me i would rather it be
her home or your home that you take over
and you say i'm gonna just
that you're you know aunt you're sick
you don't need the burden of this
i'm gonna just buy it from you and
there'll be a clean
line there so that's one conversation i
would probably have maggie this feels a
little bit
convoluted when with both of you on the
deed i don't really care for that
um but also yeah if you're not living in
the house and you guys are going to be
living with your aunt for the
foreseeable future you don't need your
other home
um but you also but also the car
payments are 28 000
which is a lot but you could work and
pay that off keep the home
rent it out do something with it because
it has great equity so it's basically do
you want to mess with the home do you
not because
if you had if you had 150 000
in student loan debt this probably would
be a different conversation but the 28
000 you probably could
put the pedal to the metal and get it
paid off quick and still have your home
if you wanted to keep it
um or you could say i don't even it's
not even worth the trouble
messing with renters any of that we're
going to just cash out get the equity
out
pay off that and have a big chunk of
change in the bank which which feels
good to me as well
what's the status of your marriage
well that's a whole nother conversation
sir that okay
um we we're like i said i just started
with the babysitters we've been coming
for 21 years we've never mixed our
finances ever
but that's something that we that i do
want to start doing now
yeah you know i just felt like it was a
waste to
you know have that second house i
totally get that
it's not uncommon that couples who have
been in your situation they've been
had parallel lives they've been married
for a long time they've had a great
relationship but they haven't been fully
together
then one of them goes to be a primary
caregiver for somebody else
and the whole thing comes unglued so i
want you to
go get with your husband and you all
have some hard conversations about
what the next 20 years are going to look
like you got a guys got to do this
together otherwise you're gonna end up
um all by yourself and i don't want that
for either of you okay
we're thinking about your marriage hang
in there maggie this is the ramsay show
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
daniel 10 14
and came to make you understand what it
is to happen to your people
in the latter days for the vision is
four days yet to come
never give up on a dream just because of
the time it will take to accomplish it
the time will pass away earl nightingale
well that's kind of d hold on let's hear
that again never give up on a dream
just because of the time it will take to
accomplish it the time will pass
anyway yeah so it's going to pass anyway
you might as well put it toward a dream
a fun there's a couple that my wife
knows back in texas and
they were talking about they were like
35 and they were
chit-chatting with one another and they
were both like man we both wanted to go
to med school
and be doctors and they went and talked
to somebody and the person said
well here's the deal you're gonna be 42
anyway
the question y'all aren't asking is do
we go to med school or not it's
when you're 42 do you want to be doctors
or not yeah and it's going to happen
that way
so why not right what is the obsession
with this so
i love that quote man figure it out good
and so good both my parents have made
major shifts later in life and it's
just as a whole new universe right i
think that's a fun
story when i hear people that yeah they
get to their
50s or 60s like you know what i'm gonna
and they just whatever it is
yeah and you're like man they just
started this whole new life like they
still haven't
it's almost how you see it right but
it's not the end no
you're just i just wanna i just wanna
slide in the end with no tread left on
the tire
yeah that's right that's right all right
let's go to bethany in scranton
pennsylvania home of the office how are
we doing bethany
i'm good how are you good are you an
office fan or you get beat up with that
all the time
hey my husband turned me into an office
band
well you married well
thank you you married well so what's up
how can we help
um i have a quick question i'm a
stay-at-home mom and my husband and i
have been
on babysit baby steps excuse me four
ish um for a while we're just not
quite at the 15 and i was just wondering
if you would ever recommend
um lowering that 15
just so that we can have some movement
in baby steps five and six
how old are you guys bethany i am
33 we're both 33. okay
and how much do you guys make my
husband makes a little under 50 000 a
year
okay and you're a stay-at-home mom you
said
um yes so the
the mathematical reason for the 15 is
that it will guarantee
that you will get to retirement with
dignity that you will have the money to
be able to
live your dreams and all of that um
and so that 15 we we stick pretty hard
on just to ensure that that's going to
happen um
but you guys for the income and
for your house specifically
um because your kid's college you're not
a bad parent if you don't pay for your
kids college like we've talked on here
that you can
you can send them to school they can do
community college for for a few years
transfer to a state school like
they can have a great and honestly by
the time your kids are in college as
we've been talking who knows what that
world is going to look like
um so if you don't have the cash to be
able to invest
right now in your kids college you're
not a bad parent but looking ahead at
the house
uh how much do you guys owe on the house
um i think around 86 186 okay
yeah so i would if i were you bethany i
would stick with that 15
for a little for a little bit longer and
then just i would i would almost um
start because of your income and
everything start chipping away a little
bit at the house if you have any to
throw
towards an esa or something it would be
very helpful for your kids i mean that's
in the order of the baby steps for sure
um but it's just gonna be a little bit
at a time like it may not just be this
this huge you know it's not this huge
shovel that you have that you're
throwing all this money at and all that
right i mean like you guys are having to
be very very diligent to do it all
right but that is what i that was my
question rachel uh bethany what's your
husband do
my husband's a pastor he's a pastor
there awesome
is there a potential for him to pick up
some
additional income on the side for a few
years to
knock that house out um
he could if if someone is going to be
driven in our house to do it it would
probably be naked
so we're just not that he's not driven
but he's
carrying a lot of hats um just he's the
only pastor on staff
um and which means he's the pastor and
plumber
and yard guy and hospital chatbot what's
y'all's um take-home pay
at uh bethany a month how much y'all
make a month a month
just shy of 4 000 i think and how much
is that mortgage payment
all right so around 650 650 okay
yeah that's not not terrible at all
yeah that percentage yeah yeah
absolutely man y'all are really trying
to do it you're doing it
um there's been seasons of my life when
they've been just that
which are seasons right which are we can
continue to
you know somebody stay home we're gonna
keep in this job
and we can do it for this season for the
next two years or three years or five
years
and then there becomes the math problem
right we either have to get to a point
where we can pay this off
or we have to get to a point where we
can reach that retirement goal
right otherwise yeah and you're gonna
continue you're gonna find yourself 43
and 53 and you're in a very similar boat
right and you're not gonna be any
further towards any of these goals at
all
right um and that's a hard place to be
good for you and your family though for
having your values and knowing who you
are and what you want to be about and
then going to make it happen
absolutely it's a little bit of that
contentment issue too bethany you know
because
unless something changes with his salary
as a pastor or something drastic i mean
um yeah the numbers are and and i think
you know god's called you to this place
if that's what you
you know you guys are in it for a reason
um i believe
in that discernment in your life and
your husband's life that you guys have
chosen this um because you know you're
called to it and so it is it's just
gonna
there's gonna be a level of contentment
um that you're probably gonna have to
find
as as a as a stay-at-home mom too um i
can just speak as a wife right
like i mean you're you're on instagram
and facebook and see it all and so
there's just a level of saying hey god
has us here for a reason and it's not
gonna be big and flashy
we're not gonna pay off the house in two
years i mean that's not gonna be the
story but that's okay
but that's okay but you guys are saying
diligent being smart
with the money that you do have and so
you guys are doing great
as somebody who um we've had this in our
home
you've had to make decisions like am i
gonna take this speaking gig for this
much money
oh sure i'm gonna stay at home oh 100
yeah and there's a real
true cost to yep my values are here
right whatever they may be
right and it's getting to that how do
you help somebody get to that content
because i struggle with that
it's hard i made this choice but living
with
what that choice means it can be hard
yes very much so i mean i
i feel like gratitude is one of the
first places to start
and i know it's kind of like the cheesy
answer but it's true but it's uh
christine kane i love what she says
she says that gratitude is not thankful
for what he's given us
it's to be thankful for what he's
entrusted to us so everyone's life looks
different
of what's what i believe in a spiritual
sense right god has entrusted
to you and what you have and so being
grateful for that
um i think a level of it is humility and
giving and serving and knowing that the
world's not all about you
yeah and that you looking up to say okay
what
what can i do to serve and help people
in bethany y'all's entire life is that
your run of service and it's and it's an
amazing calling
um and so there's a lot of that and then
i think there's takes a level of
maturity too
yeah emotional and spiritual maturity
right to be able to kind of say
okay we're here it's not always fun i'm
choosing to stay at home
i really want to go out to eat tonight
right but we made this choice that's
right and not beating yourself up when
you have those secondary thoughts right
those why can't we just go to florida
like everybody else
because we chose this yeah and you can
have both and yes right
yes that's right and it's hard i
remember talking i had two sets of
friends
and two were lawyers here in nashville
and just
working insane hours i mean like kids
were in daycare
she had mom guilt it was terrible but
they were doing it because they said
at the end of it or like we'll get to a
point where we don't have to work these
hours but we're going to make a big
income so that we can enjoy
take our kids on vacation we want them
to have experiences whatever it is so
they valued that
right or wrong people probably have
opinions but that is what they chose
where i had another friend four kids
he's a teacher yeah history teacher and
coach
she's she stays at home yep so talk
about a tight budget they just figured
out and they said yeah we know we can't
do all these things but this is what
we're choosing and that's the beautiful
thing about all this there's a level of
choice
right that we have of what you value
when you live out of those values
that's where the joy and contentment can
come back right chasing it someone
else's
that doesn't work for you well that's
another show on the books i want to
thank
james childs and kelly daniel for their
incredible engineering work
and call screening action thanks to my
good friend rachel cruz
this has been the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt-free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit daveramsey.com
show and register we would love for you
to come to nashville and tell your story
[Music]
you